[Music]
so i just flew back from los angeles i
hate flying first of all i always get a
little sensitive to my surroundings on a
flight a pilot walked on the pilot i
thought you know pilot uniform and um
his face was completely red and he was
sweaty kind of unkempt glassy-eyed and
drunk looking like fully fully drunk and
he was hitting on the flight attendant
he was like kind of aggressively and i
was straining forward to hear what he
was saying but he the flight attendant
was taller than him at one point i heard
him say um
uh so where do you live little lady and
i just love that he called her little
lady she was taller than him
i think i'd rather be flown by a drunk
person than a person who calls a woman
little lady well what about both that's
a bad combination uh you wouldn't rather
be flown by a drawing person i'd rather
be flown by a very responsible
misogynist i hope the women who are
listening to this aren't offended by
that justin wants to be flown by a
misogynist pilot
that's the sound
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long and life could be
a dream sweetheart
[Music]
with me as always is
you're biting your lower lip chris in
like a sexual way yeah it's you're
staring at me and biting your lower lip
and i know it's not sexual but
but
it's rare to see that in a non-sexual
way really
yeah not maybe no it looks really weird
is that how i look well it looks really
weird when you do it i'll stop doing it
anyway anyway we're both here hi guys
hey i made it
the pilot was not drunk the pilot was
drunk the pilot was not flying the plane
but he had his uniform on and he was
hitting on the flight attendant like he
was he had this power of a pilot he was
like
and and could not have looked more drunk
sounded more drunk so funny i think a
guy who calls a woman
little lady is
would you agree that he's either
uh
a misogynist or a hundred
right aren't those the two options left
yeah like
or bo i mean it would be both so are you
saying all a hundred year olds are
massages well
yeah we don't want to alienate somebody
that's our biggest demo yeah we have we
have a big centurion we have a 95 to 110
uh demographic
we crush actually speaking of 100 year
olds who may listen to this are um we
thought our grandmother whom we're going
to interview soon much to all of your
delights uh she we thought she was
asking how to listen to the podcast what
did she say to you she said she wrote me
an email and it was you know how are you
doing how are the dogs blah blah blah
and she said oh one more thing
how do you
stream all in capital letters how do you
stream
like eight question marks love always
grandma but but she didn't provide any
context to why she was or what she was
asking so it could be about pee it could
be it could be yeah it could be about a
babbling brook
uh but i imagine i figured it was about
the white water rafting
she wants to get into white water
rafting
for 103rd birthday
it wouldn't i mean she wouldn't it would
shock me i was going to say it wouldn't
shock me but it would but she
she's very active she
recently bragged about speaking of
streams and urinating she recently
bragged about um
not needing diapers and about how like
her younger friends
all like much younger friends much
younger like 20 years younger she has
friends who are like 83 who live in this
you know community with her and
and uh and she sees them as
like she talks about them like they're
kids kind of like
it's weird for an 84 year old person to
be uh you know described that way but
they are like a whole generation younger
than her um
and they wear diapers
and she's and then i was like i i found
it funny at first but then i was like oh
she should be bragging about this i
would i would brag about that it's an
amazing accomplishment yeah yeah um so
we'll talk to her about that shortly but
um
the point of the pilot story was uh here
i'm gonna i just found the text that i
wrote christian
um i said uh oh right you wanted a
record of your final like if that was it
i did
yeah so long story short justin became
friends with the drunk non-pilot and now
he's our guest on the show today so
please welcome he's he's sobered up
i think anyway this is the text i wrote
christian i said ah the pilot of this
flight is so red-faced
he looks like a drunk jim gaffigan i'm
actually genuinely concerned and he's
grossly flirting with the blonde
middle-aged flight attendant
uh i said i don't think he's flying and
then i wrote him just so he'd feel
better i said i don't think he's flying
he's just hitching a ride
but he's still in the cockpit that also
made me concerned that he was once i
realized he was just hitching a ride it
was like why do you have to make why
does he get to go in the cockpit he was
wasted he was he was actually in the
cockpit yes he sat in that little jumper
seat i feel like that
i didn't i didn't realize that yeah
the whole flight and then at the end he
was like you did it i saw him like kind
of get out of the cockpit
and and it was a red eye and at one
point he he made a couple trips to the
bathroom and he was so loud and i was i
was trying to sleep that alone seems
dangerous it's like it's like you know
have you ever driven a really been the
dd for a really drunk person
and there's always that possibility that
he or she could like
impulsively just grab the wheel or
something and do something crazy and
like i feel like i've tried to do that
as both a dd and a dep
you shouldn't get into dps
anyway anyway but so the point is
the point is the drawing pilot who
wasn't flying the plane
thankfully uh looked ex so much like jim
gaffigan but jim is uh our guest today
i know i'm repeating myself but he is
one of the funniest people well we have
had some very funny
show so i think it's true it bears
repeating he actually like by the
numbers
legitimately is like one of the top i
think five oh really most successful
comedians in the country the thing about
jim though is that he's
he's funny in so many ways he's also
funny
i don't know how to say this without
sounding insulting and i it comes up in
the interview but he's very funny
looking too he's got a funny and he's
got a funny delivery and he's got this i
remember when i first met him i just
really i loved being around him he made
me
he's the kind of person that makes you
laugh even when he's saying something
mundane you know when he's just like
describing what he had for breakfast
because he has this
hint of a wry smile on his face every
time he talk when he talks about certain
things and he to the point where there
have been times where i'll start
laughing and i'll go and then the smile
kind of breaks into a bigger smile i go
what what's why are you laughing you
know even when we talk about some
serious stuff and
he's so consistently funny that it's
hard to pivot with him talk about
serious stuff he's always sort of
reminded me of jerry seinfeld someone
like that yeah when i think of jim
gaffigan i always think
he's one of the rare like seinfeld one
of the very clean comics he doesn't
curse in his show and he's
which to me is always
much more impressive in a comedian i
mean you think about everyone we grew up
watching everybody all of the greats
like chaplin and marx brothers and
steve martin even like we get
getting into the 60s and 70s none of
them could cur i mean lenny bru that's
why lenny bruce broke a lot of
barriers but like yeah there were
generations of comedy before that i
don't think there's anything wrong i
think cursing can be done in stand-up
comedy can be done so effectively and
brilliantly
like bill byrd chris rock i mean those
guys use
swears in such a
i think smart way i just farted and i'm
hoping i'm far enough away from that oh
god i'm definitely far enough away from
will so it's safe there
well i think it's time to get the show
started speaking of speaking of farts
what a perfect segue um to our guest uh
who i'm sure farts i'm sure
anyway the he's known mostly as a farter
um but he also is a comedian and an
actor and just a great guy really funny
and i hope you enjoy my conversation
with jim
hello
the last time i saw you you were scruffy
and scraggly and you were really dark
you're playing this dark character in
america i saw american dream oh yeah
i've never seen you like that and
you're incredible in it thank you you
sent that to me i thought you were
sending your latest comedy special so
so i was like so excited to see it um
i'm glad i did see it because it is such
a crazy departure i'm excited about the
role but i'm also excited that
people are seeing it and that
you know the the people that make the
decisions yeah we're in the perception
business so it's like i love stand up i
am a stand-up comedian yeah but i love
acting and i feel as though
you really have to show people what you
can do when does it come out uh
september
20th okay september 13th in new york and
then september 20th nationally okay it's
weird i want to talk about it but i also
want people to go in
without with very little information
yeah because i think that that's the
best way yeah um so i'll just say to go
see it and i'll say in a very like
vague way just how dif it's just such a
different thing that i've ever seen you
do it's very strange i actually play
uh someone named drew barrymore yes
it's spelled slightly differently i
think it's it's dru that's it yeah and
then a gh but other than that it's a
full-on imitation pretty much
no you gotta do the list
so sweet yeah she's like the weirdest
person in the world jim and i know each
other well i mean we had met years
earlier but we also worked together with
drew on going the distance which
everyone must know it was a huge hit it
wasn't um justin what is going on what
is happening with life what are you
doing what is most important to you what
do you want i want to get to know you
better all right let's get to it i've
always loved your comments i've taken my
pants off you can put them back on yeah
okay i'll put them back up um
but
it's how you gesture you've got it's
just it's also you know these
it's just i didn't i couldn't find a
belt that fit it's also your thing might
be part of your my thing it's like oh
there's this this is yeah the suspenders
and like twirly photos there's a lot of
suspense in my stand up and my acting i
approach a character no go ahead where
did that voice come from because
what voice you know the one where you
question your own joke you know uh
that's something
first of all we all have inner critics
yeah but they don't who knows what they
sound like you know
but some of it is i uh yours is soft and
gentle mine is soft and gentle and a
little judgmental just slightly just a
little bit tired of dealing with you
um but i've always had this inner critic
and even as a teenager i used to speak
for other people oh really and so
and then
there's a lot of voices in my head and
i'm a slow talking midwesterner so
in my stand up i thought initially i had
to keep talking ah huh fill in the space
or people and then i if i heckled myself
that people wouldn't hack them that
makes sense you put it on yourself to
let me beat you to the point i heard
gilda radner say that in um not to me
in in this there's a great documentary
about her but she said she's like she
started making fun she started beating
the kids to the punch when they would
call her i guess she grew up she was
overweight
and so instead of before they could make
fun of her she would you know she would
do the fat jokes first and that was uh
did did were you
fat yeah
were you like killed arrested but i am
everyone listening should know that
we're sitting on exercise balls right
now yeah and jim has a headband
and his uh
what are these one pound weights they're
five wow five good for you good kilos
yeah that you're that strong you thought
yeah um you know it's all about that and
this tank top's good you know i like
this to be productive for you because i
know it wouldn't be if you're just
talking about yourself because you don't
like to talk about yourself no you know
i like to be ripped
i like to i think i have low tea i don't
know what it is i think it's low
testosterone
um
i think maybe fathering five children
took all the tea out of me uh-huh it
takes a lot of tea to it takes a lot of
tea put that many uh s's in one w yeah
and so it's like but i have low energy
like when i'm touring i'm always touring
because i just want my dad to like me i
i'm always touring and i
i need to drink a red bull before a show
cause i like to pick up my pace um you
like to keep the show more high energy
than you naturally are yeah yeah i'm
very i'm much slower and
lower energy
i like to nap i can see that yeah you
look like an apple
you're like a big cat i am a big cat
yeah am i a big kid yeah you're garfield
it's in i guess i am girlfriend yeah i'm
odie you're odie i don't know what that
is oh he's the dog who's like oh he's
like you know needing oh yeah
yeah you can't get garfield's approval i
don't know i was out playing with
friends when you were younger
but i uh i don't think i was always this
low energy well you think i'm dying
we all are yeah you were the youngest of
six i was the youngest to say and were
they rambunctious was your family like a
high-energy household you know um
i don't remember i don't think i had a
lot of energy ever this is interesting i
did this indie film i'm gonna talk about
in my films
no i did this film called
light from light which is a great
super indie kind of like one scene was
like 20 pages yeah it's like one of
those like as an actor you're like great
i can like do a couple things yeah they
laughed at you when you requested a
chair
no but when we were doing the scene
the director was like you know what i
want you to go a little slower and i was
like that's the first time i've ever had
my life because i'm slow
talking well but he is he's such a uh
grounded in
moments and realism it's vincent gallo
it was vincent gallagher i remember
jonah hill used to say he'd call himself
he when he he did a few and he did this
indeed it was his first one and he was
like
i said well what was it like he was like
i was just doing indie jonah and i said
what do you mean he's like i was just
talking slower and kind of like not
giving as much
indie
but you uh okay youngest of six don't
remember it but you must have had you
had like athletic and i didn't realize
you played football i i did play
football but i wasn't i think i just
tried really hard and i had an older
brother that was good at sports oh and
you know but you know and yeah i guess i
was an athlete a brother that you looked
up to one uh yes i wanted to be around
him yeah and stuff like that and we're
saying i'm actually i've taken over his
identity my brother's name was jim
gaffigan oh i'm actually steve oh it's
like a talented mr ripley or talent list
is that what mr ripley oh yeah i haven't
seen that in a while yeah he took over
jude law's persona i guess that's weird
because phil hoffman doesn't look like
you were in that i was now phil i'm
you're right phil no you're not i'm not
phil hoffman i guess that makes it even
jealous of i was always jealous of phil
hoff god you know i used to really have
that i used to have that about a couple
uh girls um girls oh wait yeah uh no no
i used to have that about um nora ephron
nora yeah it was mostly and
her sister uh
i had it a lot about carol carol
channing carol channing he's really
jealous similar vocal quality well you
know not anymore i changed my voice uh i
don't know whose career do you want
because the universe is listening that's
the thing you know
i'm not just saying yes i've gotten to a
place very like comfortable place that
i'd never really been in my life where i
as much as i would like certain aspects
of other careers to win to win awards to
be in like you know superhero things and
it'd be fun to do those things i don't
um here comes the lie
yeah how do i formulate this lie uh
but i don't i just want people to be
nice well i know that sounds like
[ __ ] as i'm saying it
no no no i think by the way i do think
that
you know at least for me and my career
once i
like i struggled so hard uh
like i wanted to get letterman and conan
appearing on those shows and
i kept getting rejected and then finally
i was like
i guess i'm not gonna get these shows
huh i had to come to the conclusion oh
you know what
i get to do what i enjoy
that's all that matters right and then
once i decided that then they wanted me
right and so like the whole it sounds
corny but i think it's the like the
creative fulfillment is
really the whole thing because also the
whole charade of even opening nights are
so absurd you're like didn't we see a
movie here like a week ago
but now you're in a dress for some
reason it's so weird no i know i know
some of it is you know i like
the opportunities and it is so
it's such a weird business like we are
such control freaks
who
don't i think most performers are such
control freaks who also
don't like surprises uh i mean it's like
this strange combination of yeah like we
don't want to be you know we don't want
to be on a show that goes for seven
years right we just want to get to the
job exactly
yes we want to like we want our parents
to put you know our artwork up on the
fridge and
you know then the next we draw something
else and like that goes up there i but
you know i think
as as as i'm thinking about it now i i
think a lot of it had to do with the
fact that i did covet certain things
yeah and then occasionally would even
get them
and and never really found to see that's
yeah yeah in fact the movie i think a
lot about the movie we did yeah which at
the time was like a there was like a big
chance for me there was a it was a very
loaded movie because it was the first
time i was
at whatever the studio movie and i was
with
and drew was a big star so i was it was
a
and i and i remember getting the sense
from my agent certainly like if that
movie had done well
uh
what it could have changed things you
know could have and there were a couple
parts like that that i uh didn't get or
i could whatever but i remember after
that movie uh i i didn't hear from from
the agents it was that kind of oh yeah
yeah yeah
i have a friend greg geraldo who had an
agent
who
he had this meteoric rise initially
and
his agent of uh she
brought him he got a development deal he
got a show it got on air
the show got canceled
uh he ran into the agent
like six months after the show was
canceled and she didn't even look at him
oh my god
and he was like
he was like yeah it doesn't surprise me
this was and i think she's out of the
business yeah but and i was like wow
yeah it can be that wow yeah that your
value rests so completely in that thing
that when whether and if it doesn't work
it's like well we don't even see yeah it
doesn't surprise me but but if you have
enough experiences like that or even
like versions of that
i think the lesson i learned i mean it
took me a while was that you know to not
put your own you know self value self
worth and stuff like that so it is such
a marathon anyway yeah oh my god how
many people
we both kind of came up with or yeah um
so the fact that you were coveting these
things like letterman and once they
happened
which they did um
in their what
early 2000s late 90s late 90s yeah
so did that feel what was that
fulfillment that feeling it was very um
the version of
you know it's weird because doing
letterman was the only goal
like as a comedian performing a
letterman on letterman was the only goal
that i kind of had not pilots not doing
a cigarette you know i wanted to i
always wanted to act
uh i had gotten by the way there was
there's times when uh you know uh like
when my first comedy special aired
the usa today
did a little blurb and it said sitcom
actor jim gaffigan try stand up weird so
like the perception was that i was a
sitcom guy
and they didn't know about my standup so
it's awesome that's weird it's such a
perception business right right and was
that because you've done so many you had
done tons of commercials well i done i
had a run of like being on sitcoms you
know like that 70's show and yeah i
think ed i reoccurred on end but i had
been on
that's where we met yeah and then uh the
ellen her sitcom and then i had my own
sitcom so there was a bunch of stuff
right
and
that's what i mean that's the thing i
mean this is a bit of a tantrum but i
hate
the way that um
like i never feel like i
appreciate how i'm described in an
article huh i'm always kind of like
the clean comic
you know what i mean or the comedian for
everyone you know i mean it's like what
about funny i just write funny right
that's fine i mean that's all i want
funny you know the comedian you can
watch with your 12 year old you know
it's like what about funny
you know you're not just sitting there
listening just because there's not curse
words yeah it's because it's funny
and so um i know plenty of unfunny like
clean yeah yeah
and so anyway yeah
well how did you so you didn't always
work strictly clean i mean i i was very
dirty you were yeah
i was filthy
my mother's vagina's so big you know let
me tell you something
let me ask you something yeah
there was a time when i used to smoke on
stage i swear to god
it was that part of the footage
just because you enjoyed smoking it made
you feel more relaxed i have a wildly
addictive personality yeah i'm enjoying
nicotine oh you when i was a teenager i
used to dip oh i am white trash
and um this is in indiana you were born
in illinois but but raised in indiana
yes
and i love your research you're like and
you you're geographical you're a
comedian
you once he once traveled to thailand on
a vacation and um
but you have a beard i have a beard
and i also your wife i was talking about
your
wife
we both did it
we approached from different runways so
uh
what was i talking about this is your
your closeted homosexuality yes yeah um
so
uh working on the streets
no you're making money smoking you late
i was smoking i when i started stand up
the first time i did stand up i was
essentially
the character that i am
right now
and then
i did a couple more spots and bombed and
i was like all right i gotta change my
character so i have to
i tried being more energetic i tried
what did that look like angry oh i would
have loved it i tried uh you know look
at this guy really let's go political
but uh you know it was and you know
stand-ups very much about authenticity
so eventually i went back to
but i would curse occasionally not that
much did you all did you you grew up you
don't curse that much no no in fact my
brother and i talk about this often when
i do curse because i spent so many years
of my life my formative years not
cursing it was so taboo we were very
catholic growing up
uh and when i would do it it was you
know there was always shame attached and
guilt
so i even when i say [ __ ] even the [ __ ]
there's a great neil simon play where he
he talks about characters saying uh
different diseases and they always
whisper them you know yeah
yeah and i feel that way a little bit
about cursing some of you know here's my
thing about the cursor uh some of my
favorite comedians are filthy or they
curse or whatever
i'm from a small
town where
uh that was the big shock for me when i
moved to new york city was everyone was
like this is [ __ ] hot it's [ __ ]
freezing i'm [ __ ] tired and i'm like
and i worked in an advertising agency
can you think of an adjective besides
[ __ ] we're selling like baby shampoo
yeah and they're like ah [ __ ] a
[ __ ] and they don't get any
[ __ ] tears in their little infant
[ __ ] it was it was authentic yeah
but and so like look if i stub my toe
i'll curse yeah you know it's i mean
i've done some of these jokes
15 times yeah yeah you get laughs i mean
it does occasionally get laughs but it's
cheap and it doesn't really have much to
do with you know the joke when you
unpeel the whole thing well it's and i
also got rid of not that i had that many
curse words but i was
appearing on conan like once a month
with this thing pale force and so
i realized when i was getting ready for
these sets that i would have to remove
curse words or remove
like something filthy yeah
and it didn't happen that often but it
just made me realize oh they're not done
yet and jesus told me not to well you
know where did you grow up my mother
hates when i say jesus still on the show
she'll listen and i think yeah jesus i
say it as an exclamation sometimes it's
really really wow you oh jesus i mean
it's a lot of it is woody allen i think
jesus you know you would say jesus so
where did you grow up i grew up in a
small town in connecticut oh wow and so
your mom's still very careful well my
dad was in the seminary for seven years
18 to 25. he spent a long time and so
they're the older they've gotten i think
the more devout they've gotten oh that's
yeah so and we've kind of gone the other
way much to there you know and that's
you and your brother yeah yes yeah and
you know it's so interesting
because i'm catholic yeah and i know
like there's being a browns fan where
people are like really brown that's
right right since which by the way
they're gonna be great great yeah um but
the catholic thing like it's
it's not just the recent scandals uh-huh
it's like that's hundreds of
inquisitions
yeah of
horrible
things
and but
you know what i always say you know look
america has done a lot of bad things and
i'm proud to be an american oh yeah
it's not it's not the teachings that's
wrong it's the humans yeah and that's
what your mom would say yeah
is your dad's name carl no no is it
peter jim
is it jim yeah no it's not really yes
well you know i'm your father
you could be jim long here that's pretty
good i've heard you do that voice
this is my father's voice oh yes yes yes
yeah
justy
justin yeah yes mr graffiti
how's it going uh good sir i i want to
tell you i'm a huge fan of your son i've
seen some of your girlfriends
delicious
oh thank you mr gabby i can't take
credit i'm no longer with them so so um
how long have you lived out here in la
la land oh where and you're you still
living i live in new york
in indiana i lived in illinois
oh no i uh so wait a minute so your dad
was in the seminary yeah it's funny
where it's my trying to send the seminar
too really wait a minute
we do the same thing
is your dad funny now he's not because
he's dead but thanks for bringing it up
um he died yesterday oh wow no he can't
believe you were able to do this he was
uh
unintentionally funny
what would he say about your cr when you
told him you wanted to be a comedian
well he thought i was crazy
you know like i
many generations uh you know just
totally uh getting by
and then my dad was the first one to go
to college he wore a tie to work and so
then i was like i want to go and defeat
her
and they're like all right he's gay but
um but um
i knew it i knew it no but like uh so
right you were the youngest two of us i
was the youngest of six i think they
thought
everyone passed away and so they were
my dad was kind of like it's just an
eccentric thing
just uh but then when i started having
some success they're like we always know
you guys
right
we always do it yeah yeah i wanted you
to struggle because that's important so
like my dad was in the town newspaper
and stuff like that so he loved it
yeah of course of course did he remarry
after your mom he did well and did you
get along with her yeah sure that's just
weird though it must be it's very weird
your parents are still alive yeah yeah
as far as i know that you know um
depends when someone's listening to that
oh god because
these are gonna be so popular yeah that
in a hundred years they'll continue to
listen so like when people major in
podcasts like people in 20 years they're
like what's your major i'm majoring in a
podcast yeah and you're a city ticker
i'm taking the justin long uh what's the
name of your podcast
i don't want to say now because you're
going to make fun of it what is it
life is short life is short
see i said in a self-deprecating way in
your voice what's the premise like
welcome to life is short with jessa long
you know i just want to get to know
people we're going to use this by the
way
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men valued for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
you were talking about catholicism adam
curious if you still are you you were
equating it to you were saying how awful
it's been throughout the age
but right now to be a catholic
is that difficult is it difficult to
even talk about yeah i mean i don't know
if there's also something
you know i think comedians like to do
things that
you know bucking the system or yeah you
know what i don't care what you think
i'm doing this yeah
in some ways is that yeah
so it's true but it is very complex
because there's not you know
a week of the news where i don't go what
the hell yeah
so but it is also very individual you
know what i mean my dad i'm also too
lazy to find enough
you spent so long you know cultivating
yeah i don't know
yeah catholic you don't have to know
that much well that's the thing i mean
like
even growing up in it it was uh certain
sex were
different than others you know
yeah or like protestantism was like oh
they do it kind of wrong and we do it
right
and my dad reads a publication called
common wheel now which he says is a like
a more progressive oh right catholic
public oh you know what's so interesting
is
there by the way i have been protested
by westboro baptist church oh wow what
was that like
well it was just online but yeah
supposedly they uh we're going to
protest my show i think they're in
kansas yeah and because my kids that's
why i can never make the meetings had um
gone to uh they were at a park
and the pride parade was happening it
was a couple years ago yeah and they got
flags and they got a picture of all my
kids you know two of them were in the
stroller holding these pride flags
and i posted this instagram thing i'm
saying i'm so proud of my gay kids
most of them were like two and four yeah
obviously a joke
people were so angry
and so that's the thing where i'm like
crazy
it's just
you know it's like but i also was it
just the sergeant was it the fringe was
it like like westboro it's like yeah
it's kind of a batch of honor to be
experienced but like there are people
that
really
i mean there's the people that are
obviously me thinks the lady yeah yeah
yeah and then there's the people that
they're like no that's
against the teaching of the catholic
church and you're like
you know i mean so it's
there's a lot of things yeah yeah i mean
it's like are these
are these people horrible or they just
you know they're doing something
different than you yeah yeah but so so
so how do you reconcile because i have a
hard time reconciling that with like
what my and my parents
they don't think gay people shouldn't be
allowed to be married all those things
but and yet they're still they're
catholic well i think that it's like
you know america has a very complex
history yeah and i'm proud to be an
american hell yeah no you know what i
mean so
it's human beings are so flawed right so
it's like everyone's flawed by the way
it's except for me of course
but i think that
and and by the way people can i mean in
the entertainment industry there are
people that you meet
that are decent people and then you can
meet them again in five years and they
might not be that decent and then you
can are you looking at me ten years
later yeah no and then you can meet them
10 years later and they're back to
normal yeah yes you're i mean yeah yes
but i think there was a you're talking
about going the distance during that
time and like do i covet other careers
and whatnot i think during that time if
ever i was to go kind of off the rails
or
get get away from who i am or how my
parents raised me it was would have been
during that time oh really yeah of
course i mean
i think you know you find yourself
getting used to being treated a certain
way and getting you know there's certain
there's a and i'd have to check myself
unfortunately i have really good friends
who would make fun of me if i started a
veer and that yeah well i mean that's
where all that's also
in some way there's many reasons why i
don't live in l.a besides that i'm i
would just be harassing women oh yeah
yeah i mean you wouldn't be believing
and um
but some of it is
i think that
and this is going back but like uh
back 15 years ago i'm like i can't be in
this
powder keg of comparison yeah where like
and that's more of a commentary on me
than los angeles yeah you're only
insecure
am i doing well enough like i remember
when i was
on some shows out here friends that you
know are great people they'd be like
dude you have to get a better car you
can afford a better car and i'm like do
i need another car yeah and and i would
be like i'm not getting another card
like get another car your car is
embarrassing yeah and people would like
you're right like good values like yeah
and some of it they were joking but like
it's also it's just like i don't know i
think that you know like you talk about
being around friends that can ground you
it's like i meant the people on friends
yeah friends yeah you know mostly
yes yeah matt really keep the [ __ ]
language
um
but she like cox theaters
like when you do promos for movies and
they're like hey come see this movie at
cox theater
it's unbelievable is there a cox
theaters yes or cox cable oh you know
uh now you know
uh now appearing on
cox cable and you're like what
i can't believe i'm saying that of
course everyone else is like is he a
child and i'm like i am a child
shocks it's a great word especially when
uh it doesn't mean
what it could mean when it's just
somebody's name would you say i'm the
best guest uh so far
how many guests have you had two you had
walton goggins uh-huh i worked with him
wait why'd you say walden goggins we
haven't but i know all right wait a
minute didn't you have walton coggins
no that's really funny you had sam oh
maybe you had uh sam rockwell yeah yeah
how do you know east coast theater
um
yeah no but like same intense kind of
southern insane pearson yes yeah same
level man did i show you his house did
you take a house no but he is like the
sweetest intense lunatic yes you know
what i feel is so interesting
they're
i mean i have low t i don't know what
that means low testosterone i think so
you look a lot like a far side character
i thought that that's an insult
well if i didn't say it i was gonna
forget it would be how would that be a
compliment you look like you know like
gary larson draws exaggerated ugly
versions of humans you look like that
that's not true
no it's completely true
but here's the thing i have this theory
that uh and by the way i get along with
all these guys i would just like to
paint a picture right now for the
audience that you have kicked your feet
up onto this other chair that is between
us yes and you're because i have low t
yeah oh you're trying to increase your
i just yeah i got to get my ball good
your balls went up
because they were dragging on the ground
no but like here's the thing i have a
theory that a lot of
like
i don't know if this is true about brad
pitt but a lot of the big time actors
that i've worked with
are type a's
like you're not a type a no god no but
like okay leaves a type a yes walton's a
type a jason clark's a type a i don't
know um
uh
that's why i can only name three um no
jason
taipei kiefer sutherland
uh who else is the type as you're saying
right they're all taipei's and by the
way i get along with guys like that i
get it you've worked with a lot of big
actors you know what i'm trying to say
is if you guys check out my imd what you
do like why is my imd like do you ever
look at your imdb page and you're like
why the hell is that
beautiful woman who's beautiful
she's like got an imdb score of like 51
and she's been in like one movie
that no one saw and i'm still at like 6
000. why is that
i don't know how do they do those
rankings i don't know let me go back to
acting like i don't care
everyone go to my i am the wait page and
boost it up maybe that's what it is just
the number of
even my imdb page has low tea
we'll see now that'll be my new nickname
yeah the old lodi
this is another example of why you
prefer living in new york i mean you're
floaty loti and the imdb problem well
it's just it's
you don't have any control out here did
you ever meet phil hoffman i did what
was that like was it like did you do the
whole mirror thing for the marx brother
we did it was kind of like have you ever
seen the image of the two spidermans um
bob
name drop name drop yeah let me get that
he
he did this a couple times but he was
like i'm going to improvise a movie
you know obviously waiting for goffman
yeah and those types christopher guests
had already done it so he got together
all these people and this was before
phil was gigantic
i was like so
phil and i should play brothers and then
and he's like
how about friends and i'm like what all
right oh my god right
i
i remember we would improvise
and he pulled together a script
but and i saw bob balaban later on and
he was like you know phil exploded so he
he's not available oh my god isn't that
amazing so he would record what you guys
were improvising but there was all there
was so like he would he would direct
scenarios and he did it with
he did something he went to the academy
awards and everything yeah and you know
like a british one or a period thing yes
um
and uh
yeah i think it was that was it yeah and
it was really uh interesting because i
remember even seeing
philip seymour hoffman and things and
going everyone that guy looks like
oh i wish he's all he was also such a
yeah he was a great guy and so how did
you know him uh i met him
i met him out here sam and i were doing
galaxy quest my first oh yeah john my
first kind of that was your first big
guy yeah because he was friends with sam
sam rockwell and oh my god i was
obsessed with phil at the time yeah
boogie knights had come out and happened
oh my gosh it was like he was i just
dropped out of school yeah cause i
wanted to be like him i mean yeah
um and and sam casually mentioned yeah
you know hey my friend phil's coming
coming by uh
and i i rarely get
that star struck you know like where i'm
behaving in a weird way and i got it was
tough to be around him and then we got
to kind of know each other over the
years you know it's so
i mean i i know nothing about him but
it's so interesting
um how
i mean some of it he was a great actor
but it's almost kind of like
looking like him yeah and
like he was so
adored and then like my article's like
yeah he's comedian
it's like
it's just like i look like him and
they're like oh it's so fascinating this
white bread guy and then i'm like hey
i'm white bread too and they're like
yeah there's a lot of you
it's like i can't imagine what it'd be
like to look it's like me looking like
daniel day lewis and like you don't oh
you're good
thank god
i was fishing for um
yeah i can't imagine that are you
interested but that's why seeing
american dreamer was oh did you say
yeah because like oh that's a part phil
would have played and and you guys were
playing it and similarly like oh that's
true it's a huge i mean i mean that is a
compliment like i watch phil's acting
and i'm like
he's not doing anything yeah and i'm not
criticizing it no in a great way i'm
just saying that
it's just fascinating yeah to go from
boogie nights to like um big lebowski
character there's they're both
submissive characters but they're
and the voices are similar but they're
wildly different people it's really
interesting how uh
i don't know it's all fascinating but
but we'll be right back but
but uh but back then when you were
you were trying on these different
personas as a stand-up did you harbor
ambitions to also totally i always
wanted that uh-uh i read out of course i
always wanted that in college even
in college yeah yeah i know the night
before i graduated from college you went
to purdue i went to purdue and then
georgetown right and the night before
graduation i was at a bar and i was
talking to a friend and i told her i was
like god you know i just want to be an
actor and a comedian but
everyone wants to do that she was like
not everyone wants to do that i didn't
believe her
i assumed everyone wanted it yeah and i
still think well everyone wants to i
think a lot of people fantasize about it
but but wouldn't have they wouldn't
trust whatever yeah because it's an
insane pursuit which is my
another one of my theories that the dad
in um
uh
[Music]
the
dead poet society oh yeah what's right
oh what now what does he say to
he says don't be an actor
kid kills himself that's right
so you think the kid was
the dad was the dad
[Laughter]
did you uh does this make me more
likable
it's a different it's a different you do
you record things do you record funny
ideas yes i do i'll write down ideas
things that i think
excuse me i actually just it's so weird
that i'm sitting on the toilet while
we're doing this i know and you've been
going the whole time
you know what it's like you know what i
just gotta you can you can get rid of
some of the noises okay good but um
we're gonna do it write down ideas
i can't believe you're not done
defecating by the way well you know the
thing is i had i had uh taco bell okay
so um i'll write down things so what is
this
that doesn't make sense people telling
you
who they are
that nothing there
oh i'm so curious just no excuse no but
i'm trying to think of like um
like is this
uh
oh like i was in ireland and i did some
shows i'm like how like here's notes how
do you tell the difference between any
of those 10 whistle songs
um uh
um how did they respond to that because
i don't think i even did uh uh but like
that's more of an american irish joke
yeah
they they wouldn't appreciate it
but the uh talking about and just you
know like but different things that kind
of
bump you annoy you then you'll write
them down and and it's not for me it's
not funny when it's anger it's
it's funnier when it's
an observation when it's turned into an
observation um
i i i hate to ask about this because you
you're probably sick of talking about
hot pockets yeah
yeah well okay good
um
is that is that a reference people make
when they see you oh yeah yeah
yeah like when you do podcasts it's
interesting because like on instagram
like if if anyone uh on my stories if
they post a video like hey i'm watching
jim gaffigan i'll restore it but
anything that has to do with half
packages
i don't restore it oh so you won't you
won't post about this if you don't if
the hot buckets makes the final cut
well no yeah i mean this is i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna listen to this
so i can see you listen to all of them i
too to do editing notes yeah yeah oh you
do yeah i like because it's it's funny
it's a thing i started doing purely for
fun i thought it'd be a lark um and it
has remained fun but i found myself
getting very and i've been very invested
in it in a way that i surprised you yeah
and is it one of those things where
you have an idea of what you're going to
talk about and then you get in you and
you're like oh my gosh i didn't end up
talking about anything sometimes yeah
yeah so to yeah do you always do your
interviews in a boost ea i think it's
weird no i thought i'd keep you guys i'm
just joking he's not wearing a bustier
anymore
[Music]
hello hello again
how did you meet your wife i met her in
a korean deli in my neighborhood oh
really and we realized we had a lot in
common
and then we had a bunch of kids and i
got really fat you you were
oh you were sin at the time i was thin
oh really what'd you play in football
what position did you play uh stud yeah
no i played uh defensive end and
offensive uh center i can't find this
wow i can see yeah so you must have been
you must have been big but you sturdy i
was sturdy i had uh you know i could
walk so why is it that you gained the
weight after you had the kids i know
what's that all about it's called
sympathy way oh that's very nice
you're very empathetic breastfed
[Laughter]
you're five you know this there are
other things that stay with you and
you're like
like the breast friend like there's
certain things that are so bad i love
them like
i'm on turtle time no
i love that i love it where is that from
it's just we were in north carolina and
there's turtles there so there's all
these shirts that say i'm on turtle time
oh really i just love horrible jokes you
know what i mean i must have like got
milk
got something else oh i love those
shirts well those shirts and my brother
we call them ruddy face pleasure hounds
yeah they're those guys like jimmy
buffett fans who like just like drink
you know it's five o'clock somewhere
kind of thing yeah but like like key
west or savannah any southern fun time
city which i love they have those
t-shirt shops that are like
uh you know designated uh boob checker
yeah you know
boob inspector
muff diver yes yes i'd rather
yeah like i'm with stupid and pointing
to its penis you know yeah uh i don't
blame me he wanted to be here
and it all has to do with being drunk or
like being horny yeah all those shirts i
like them because my friend we try to
pick out the worst one and the and the
the bet is to see who can wear it um you
know and you have to get it's a fun game
to play if you're in a place like that
it's funny so you pick one out for your
wife she picks one up for you and you
have to commit to wearing some wearing
it and some are like really horrible you
know right some are like you know uh
yeah what's the one like hand lotion
dispenser down there and it's like
ugh is that there are kids in the store
yeah like
um it's the opposite of your humor what
inspired you to write clean uh
so that chara do that character that
like kind of uh self-deprecating like
questioning character do you remember
when you started doing and realize that
it worked and continue oh in stand-up
yeah i
well it worked
off and on yeah because when it didn't
work the people it was really awkward
it would be really kind of like wow this
guy's the worst comedian ever
but it's bold it's it's yeah
it's like some people wouldn't figure it
out they're like what's he doing well
for the
well for those listening and not
familiar which i don't imagine there are
many you'll say something funny
and then afterwards you'll come through
this for yourself that's really weird
yeah why are you laughing at me i don't
know why i oh i heard him on the podcast
yeah he was different than i thought i
was listening with a child and i didn't
appreciate the language
right
yeah i just i i'm friends with justin's
mother and i like jim gavin i thought i
did
so much for the whole catholic thing
yeah what happened to that uh yeah but
it's something that um when it it's it's
also very unique it must be hard to
stand out well it's also you can't do it
too much uh-huh yeah yeah cause
it's then it's
better in small doses
i think do you ever plan out when you're
doing it you're just going to do it i'll
do it without anything without any of
that
and then i'll sprinkle it out because it
adds kind of an improv element yeah
and sometimes it's different depending
on the show or the situation if it's
like
cold outside oh i can't well i guess
it's better to be here than outside
do i mean
but it's also like what's great about it
too is you get to if something doesn't
get the the response you want you can
always yeah
use it and it communicates an awareness
yeah yeah i was like i'm doing a thing
uh you i'm aware that i'm doing so many
jokes on horses yeah
yes yeah
you uh
do you what are your kids now that you
have five last time i saw you in fact
you were
wrangling them and i felt bad for even
stopping you and saying hi because they
were so where was that it was on the str
uh in the west village or
is that difficult to walk around
the city with those kids being with kids
is horrible yeah
yeah you have five i know there's just
ways why'd you do that
i don't know no it's great it's just a
lot of work but uh
you know it's but it was fodder it's
become fodder for your uh certainly for
your standard but also you developed a
show
yes and some of it is but it's a balance
because
uh when i started stand up i would see
comedians
talk about their wife or their husband
or their kids
and i didn't have i couldn't get a date
i was like who is this person yeah i
don't know yeah i don't want to hear
this so i'll do some of it but
in small quantities it's not always the
most relatable especially with five and
you write with your wife as well which
is yes
so does that make it easier in some way
no no
sorry
why are you crying
no it's it's we write together but it's
it it varies like there's no consistency
to how we go about that writing together
so like when we had no children
we could sit and drink wine and talk
you're beating me right now i'd like you
guys
one or two yeah manageable we'd wait
till they'd fall asleep and then she
you know and now it's like
did you see that joke and she's like i
think so
you know it varies yeah yeah how much of
it when you're writing down these funny
things so you do it at home with the
kids if the kids say something funny or
do something funny so yeah some of that
and sometimes and then i'll be like
i'm going to do a set i'm going to try
these jokes and you know i'll just say
them and yeah you know but like my kids
are like you're not funny
what are they
they must be
what do they find funny they're funny
what about what you do do they find the
most the funniest
what do they respond oh
well you know it's weird it's a little
bit of a
a teasing thing but it is very strange
because
when i'm with them people will say
i like your your dad's funny must be so
fun and they're like huh
so it's weird well it's all they know
yeah they probably you know they're when
they grow up they'll probably have an
appreciation for maybe maybe if they
talk to me
well you've set low standards jesse i
have to go okay
i have to go i have diarrhea whoa we
just ended up this toilet is full
[Laughter]
uh you
i don't want to i don't know how to go
from diarrhea to
tumors oh yes a couple years ago you're
really serious your wife did she had a
benign she had a brain tumor yes
what was that does that just throw
everything into oh my gosh different
perspective
you know it's insane
because uh you know i'm
you know i love being a
father but i mean i wasn't doing
all the work
right and so when my wife uh you know
when we discovered this brain tumor and
there was very kind of touch and go
situations
i was like all right well i guess i'm
retiring if i'm going to be a single dad
because i can't really outsource it
so it got it went there i mean that's
right it got really serious yeah and and
so and you know and then my wife kind of
came back like she had a tracheotomy and
she had
you know
she had a nine hour surgery yeah and
then she had pneumonia where she was you
know it was very touch-and-go
and so i was
uh
so it was really serious but
it's and then of course she's you know
her 80 she's probably at 80 but her 80
is like a normal humans 100 percent oh
she's at 80 now yeah healthwatch so
health-wise you know yes i mean she's
like you know she wrote a book the books
coming out in october so oh she's she's
uh she's on the mend but
it is a full
you know journey yeah you know i mean
this was how long ago that yesterday oh
no wow it was again you had a big day
yesterday it was
it was i guess
was it last year no maybe it was the
year before it's all a blur
i remember the thing yeah yeah yeah
but but in terms of having to see your
life you had to you you you were forced
to kind of conjure this image of what
your life would look like yes and i had
to
resign myself to the fact okay
i've
had some
i've really enjoyed doing stand-up yeah
and some acting but obviously i
you know if these children are going to
lose their mother i'm not going to be
like i'm doing stand-up right here i
mean
i have to be there
so what would that have looked like i
mean what would you do i
i wonder how much i would weigh but i
would um
no i would
i couldn't
tour doing standing i couldn't do stand
up but believe me
with five children age five to
six to 15. oh my god
you know when i'm home
it's like it's full bored and you know
like the commitment
of like just school and yeah you know
it's and you don't strike me as like a
nanny guy is like someone who would
we have a i mean well that's the thing
it's like there's difference between
like getting help
to pick a kid up yeah or there when you
have five
but there's a lot of stuff that
you gotta be there yeah i'm saying that
from l.a when my children are in new
york but
well you're doing something very
important right now yeah i'm doing a
podcast yeah and free but and lucrative
and lucrative but it's like there are um
but you know like there's one thing you
know to have and that's why we stopped
doing the jim gaffigan show was
it's one thing to have one parent be
gone right
but as you know with tv shows
that's 12 yeah 14 hours a day that's
right you and your wife were doing it
together yeah so it was no
uh
it was not something that you can like
just and it's just
you couldn't we couldn't outsource it
because it was autobiographical
yeah
so what does that day look like now i
mean obviously you're not there now but
with all those kids at home six to
fifteen yeah what what is your day how
have you had to adjust your career and
your
well it's
you know my wife is back so i'm
definitely the priority
uh is you know i have a greater
appreciation for the opportunities to do
stand-up and
and to do some of these acting roles but
there's nothing typical about it it's
like you know there's a christ there's
five possibilities of crisis good lord
and there's five unique
there's five possibilities of friends
birthdays their birthdays friends
you know after-school activities there's
tons of stuff to do yeah and they're my
children so they're crazy yeah so it's
like they all look like you
too it's really funny
so yeah
and and so doing now touring you're
touring with this stand-up special you
have coming out on amazon well first of
all
was that weird to break because they all
seem to be coming out on netflix now i
think this is the first
special amazon originally original
that amazon's releasing yeah
what was that like to break with the net
you know well you know it's
i have five specials on netflix
and the netflix um
you know there's different you know
there's
different opportunities
different places yeah i mean and so
some of it is amazon is huge
and amazon is even bigger in some
countries than netflix so yeah certainly
in brazil yeah and and and england the
uk and germany and india
and so
you know the the stand-up comedy
special business is different every five
years so like my first special
you know hbo was the most prestigious
but comedy central was the most
effective place to release a special and
then
it changes every five years and so
uh you know netflix is now
uh probably a preeminent destination but
it's i almost wonder if it's
i mean who knows there's gonna be other
players that get into this like disney's
getting in yeah brothers well there's
certainly there's certainly you should
start your own streaming service i am
justin yeah long dot com yeah it's a
platform just for i mean
we like to do a lot of uh prop uh
comment yeah and none of it is visual so
it can be audio audio prop comedy yeah
that's funny um
the
thanks
they're funny um okay we're almost done
yes is that sad or we can it's super sad
you do a lot of charity work i do um is
that something you enjoy talking about
you know what's something that's good so
my wife
survives this brain tumor yeah
so she gets out of the brain tumor
starts writing this book
when life gives you pears and then
she starts this
uh because it was a pear-shaped ah
and so then she starts this
youth organization where it's combining
all these volunteer groups and it's
called
uh the imagine society so different
non-denominational you know they just
have to be like a youth group that helps
like people and they all get them
together so that they can meet and hang
out and eat pizza oh wow and it's like
it's a really cool thing she's doing
that
and i'm like going out to dinner with my
age but you know which helps well you
know you but it's like that's why it's
good to be around someone that's yeah
i'm doing the priorities yeah how much
that did that change your perspective
you talk about wanting things and not
getting the you know we were talking
about that earlier you know chasing
coveting certain things
when she went through this seeing
somebody so close to you go through this
does that change all of that does that
erase
that she had just
survived more or less yeah and i had
this album
and this special coming out
so they're like you need to do press for
it oh my god i'm like is it necessary
my wife got through all this and she
wanted to communicate to people
about her experience yeah and so she you
know when she got out of
like uh you know
it was apparent that she was gonna be
fine she was like she wanted me
to communicate to people on social media
that she was okay because that gave her
so much comfort that yeah that that
somehow it was indirectly helping people
yeah well it probably was so it was
weird so like we did like people
magazine stuff that wow i would feel
like
i wouldn't
want to do yeah but she wants she goes
you know she wants people to know that
you can go through this
which sounds weird no no it makes sense
especially especially considering yeah
that must have been such a source of
like comfort for her yeah yeah
she's so so she likes people i don't
yeah well you balance each other well
yeah so together you're kind of neutral
with people uh we're together we're kind
of like you yeah
that was hurtful that was not fair that
was that was magical i gotta go to
dinner i know okay uh um okay these are
quick all right
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say your go-to you're texting
your wife oh that's interesting
i
don't really use them never
that being said probably the next time
you see me i'm like you know now i'm
using emojis
but i would say this is my first time
trying to get out of a chair uh
i would say
i would like to get to the point where
i'd use prayer hands uh-huh in a very
sarcastic way
because i don't think anyone ever uses
prayer hands properly anyway do they
it's that i use it sarcastically in that
like hollywood bow kind of way like
thank you so much
thank you prayer yeah right i'm gonna
send you that when we leave okay this
long uh or eggplant that would be like
well you gotta go the cherries the
eggplant and the little water droplets
that's disgusting
that's an early 90s gaffigan emoji
sequence what is your
my mom what's with the cherries
uh if you could be a professional
athlete what sport
what would you play would it be football
oh my gosh
dressage uh
why wouldn't he think it would be it
would be uh um
uh limbic dancing um i don't even know
what is that you to the symmetrical the
thing with the
i'd use the ball on the stick
uh no i would uh rhythmic
i i don't know what i would do with the
ribbons i've got low teeth so i don't
know whatever i do something low t
oriented like um or like luge i guess
they just put you in the thing yeah
that's that seems stressful yeah
let's keep that one maybe i would do the
uh
push the puck across the thing curling i
feel like there's a lot of guys that
look like me that do that already
well good so you wouldn't feel like uh
oh i would fit in an outlier uh if you
could have one snack food for the rest
of your life what would it be
it depends it goes i go through
different phases
what is your thing if i could only have
one i think it'd be pizza flavored
goldfish oh really i love them i could
go through a chessmen i love pepperidge
farm then we're not sponsored by them
right
um
now i'm at like this morbidly obese page
like a lot of a lot of people don't know
that like they had to knock down a wall
together yeah
i wasn't going to say anything but it's
just like you know when i was like going
sideways and i was like hey justin but i
was facing the wrong way like you're
like hey here i come here i come and
then i was like farting too i was like
yeah well i just thought that was a joke
but peanut butter pretzels
those have done me in peanut butter
covered pretzels no no it's peanut
butter there's a nub of peanut butter
and oh
yes
yeah a nub uh what's your favorite movie
of all time i used to say
the apostle hmm
which really i i thought that was a
great movie it is a good movie yeah um
oh yeah he's but what he's just i'd be
really nervous to meet him robert duvall
i would probably be nervous to meet him
yeah because he's type a
yeah yeah he's type a plus he i feel
like any amount of gushing that i would
want to do i'd have to really curb
myself i wouldn't do any gush no no he
wouldn't want it if you had to live
somewhere else where would it be
other than new york and you probably
wouldn't live in l.a
i don't know i like ireland
you were there for a comedy tour uh just
a comment and then we have friends there
but i would say ireland or
tokyo i love tokyo have you ever played
there yeah what is that like i travel to
these places and i'll come up with
material just for there oh oh
and sometimes it you know so i did
like 20 minutes of stuff just about asia
and then i'm gonna do stuff just about
canada and i'm gonna do stuff just about
spain oh i'd love to see the tokyo one
um you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met
who i've never met
well i probably i might have met him
when i was
i would say my mother's father uh
i would say
my
dad's father
oh you never met your grandfather sir um
you know just because i oh yeah that's
so interesting that's why i love or or i
would say
one of the immigrants that i'm related
to who came over yeah you know like what
were they like you know what did they
aspire to there's a thing again there's
another like italian sponsor
ancestry.com is a sponsor so i did that
and i found uh on my dad's side i found
out that i was related to this guy who
had started open this theater and he had
this whole life and it was so
interesting just to see and there's a
single photo of him and i was
the all the stories that conjured and
and
have you ever done anything like that
like uh i did it because i so you're
german and what german polish there's uh
all that just that region and i was a
little disappointed that there wasn't i
think there was like five percent jewish
i thought there was more no i thought
for sure there was more no i thought for
sure i'd have some jewish i know i don't
look at it but i'm like it's like as a
comedian you're kind of like i gotta
have something right well it's the humor
but it's also the guilt catholic guilt
maybe supplies um i'm mostly just irish
in english yeah i thought for sure i'd
have scandinavian oh yeah yeah you do
look nordic all right well i gotta go
all right i want to thank my guest jim
gaston
a really great uh your favorite muppet
who's your favorite who do you identify
with oh not them up here beaker's mine
really of course yeah
because that was a running joke with um
oh really me me mimi and then yes so she
would be your bunsen honeydew
yeah but even though i'm probably more
abundant right physically yeah yeah um
if you could have one superpower what
would it be
i'd just like to have energy uh if you
could be a non-human animal what would
you be i guess a dog or a dolphin
i just mentioned you it's a dolphin
smooth like dolphin uh dogs are cats do
you prefer i'm dog yeah um orange juice
uh lots of pulp some pulp no pulp
grapefruit juice okay uh and do you
think about your epitaph uh any uh do
you wanna be buried do you how do you
want to go i just want to do something
where i won't be known as the hot pocket
guy okay okay that's all i want okay
it's it's interesting that that's one
thing of all the
that that has been i mean seven
[Music]
all right and you've never do you ever
repeat that joke i mean do you do i'll
do it sometimes do you talk about how
annoying it is to no no because i don't
want to complain yeah yeah well too late
in a show right
no this isn't a show well you know part
of it too is like it's it's ironic
because what you're making fun of is the
the jingoey element of it that kind of
like um
addictive quality to the to the hot
pocket you know you know what's so
amazing is i'm criticizing it yes yeah
and people think that you're celebrating
it yes
it's a disgusting yeah and then they'll
go on to list five other jokes and i'm
like
why only that one
anyway
okay yeah you got to go everyone uh
watches quality time and time amazon
not netflix
amazon and then american dreamer which
is good
american dreamers very good and and if
you're a fan of jim's comedy you won't
see any of it in american dreamer but
yeah but you'll see some great acting by
the way you should tell people that
you've had me in a hole the entire time
oh do you mind if you're like just throw
scraps
in a bucket and you reach it down them
uh now you can go now i'll release you
all right uh thanks buddy thank you
so that gaffened oh lordy lordy lord
we should change it up so
yeah it did and and uh what'd you what
did you think he talks about how he
talks slowly but he talks
slowly and deliberately for the most
part
and he talks about being slow in general
with things and i found myself
really enjoying it because of that
because it really lets you forces you to
kind of like zero in exactly it forces
you to kind of hang on
every word that someone's saying when
they say it deliberately
and i re and the more i thought about i
was like i think i just like slow people
in general
and then i thought i think i'm slow
and then i thought i think i like myself
i
that's so funny i yeah i'm trying to
think of example like he like says
things in a very kind of deliberate way
wow is that midwestern i think so well
he talks about that yeah when he talks
about not uh cursing having a clean show
he was like i'm a guy i'm a guy from the
midwest it would have been inauthentic
if i
any any dabbled in that he tries i would
love to hear that or when he used to
smoke on stage i can't believe that i
can't imagine that yeah but but again
that that would have that was
inauthentic for him well but here's the
thing jim does have a dark sense of
humor he certainly wasn't clean in this
park he recognizes really like darkly
funny things he's got this like kind of
like twinkle in his this like kind of
mischievous tweet he says dirty things
but he doesn't say them with dirty words
you know what i mean like he doesn't
swear right but he says filthy things
but that's gonna take a lot of
confidence for someone who does kind of
speak slower i'm thinking of like
stephen wright like you know yeah
comedian who that
for someone like that to be attempt to
do comedy is very gutsy you know because
if they're not funny if the material
itself is not strong then it's just so
boring well i think to that point um
that's why he created that
alter ego that that kind of greek chorus
in a way and he said before i thought
that was really interesting that before
the audience can heckle him he kind of
beats them to the punch by heckling
himself
i can't believe you just said that it's
funny it's like a geek chorus
you know i and i've noticed this about
stand-up comedians on other podcasts i
think there's an inherent
need for them to try to be funny
and it comes off sometimes as
like trying a little bit like they're
not really listening i you know because
yeah and i thought that and as i as i
cut you off i'm not listening to you um
in general you you're very funny i think
and he's very funny i think and you kind
of took turns being funny sometimes
instead of kind of dancing together
being funny yeah i know what you mean
there was there was one moment where he
started treating me like an audience
member it felt yes he totally flipped it
yeah i forget what what the thing was
that that started that but i think
he whatever was he didn't want to be
talking about something about himself or
about his
his life in some way i think and i don't
know and he was like what about you what
are you and he was like who are you
jealous of and he was i thought it was
weird too that he was really fixated on
this idea that you must be
yes jealous of people and and he was
aware of his imdb rating yeah for a guy
who's this like ho-hum midwestern guy
he seems very um aware of his
like where he is in his career and he's
focused on i think he's ambitious he's
clearly ambitious i haven't looked at
imdb rate i forgot that they rated me
too i forgot that exactly
that existed
in any way or wherever but again not a
bad thing it's just surprising with jim
because you're right he has that who
cares like yeah um it surprised me how
much he loves acting did that surprise
you yes yes that shouldn't but even but
he put it right up there he's like i
love stan
comedy and i love acting and i don't
know him so who am i to judge this but
he never struck me as someone who
was you know he did all those
commercials and i know
i guess maybe i just haven't seen him do
a lot of real acting no and i mean i
guessed much to his chagrin i forget
when this happened but it was totally
out of the blue he was in the middle of
saying something and you
totally out of the blue say
you look like a far side character
and it made me laugh so hard
because it was
it was the perfect timing it was so
random that you said that and also his
reaction made me laugh even harder he
goes he goes that's an insult
but
you know what i
sometimes i can't hold things in i just
couldn't and now you know i think jim is
actually maybe a little more sensitive
to stuff like that than i would have
thought he he i get why you wouldn't
think he would be because he's very
self-deprecating in his act he's about
always
weight yes but again it's different when
you say it about yourself
you know um i like his take on
catholicism there's constantly [ __ ] in
the news you're you you know you can't a
week doesn't go by when you're not like
great another thing about
but he was like i'm just too lazy to
find another one like i've been doing it
for so long
yeah
it's really funny you guys talk about
those novelty t-shirts like uh that we
used to wear in new orleans yeah and and
some of them are so filthy but
what you say
at the end is so much more inappropriate
than anything that's ever been on one of
those shirts you say they have jizz
jokes on them
yeah and jizz joke is maybe the grossest
combination of two words i've ever heard
hashtag
jokes
yeah that's gross i was surprised that
he couldn't pick one snack food but then
i thought
i know that kind of makes sense that he
he'd be torn between many different
types of snacks because he talks in his
act he talks about of different types of
snacks he likes a lot well you know it
was also at the time
that he wanted to go he wanted to go
yeah there was a time in the interview
where i he had he was talking about his
low t and then the t just got really low
you know it went away he lost all his
teeth
it was replaced with a like annoyance
yeah um yeah he wanted to go and he and
it was like why my favorite muppet i
just remember thinking oh these are dumb
questions why am i
because well throughout throughout the
interview i'm nervous he kept kind of
making fun of the podcast which i which
i thought was funny yes about his
wanting to leave i want to say you i was
really impressed that you
were very persistent i would have folded
it he was like uh i gotta go you were
like okay hold on i i just had a couple
more questions you were persistent with
keeping him there i thought it was
i thought it was good well he's someone
that i've known for long i feel
comfortable enough with him to do that
where like
you know and he was playful enough with
me and some of that i have to go stuff i
think may have been
maybe it was just for the show maybe
you're getting more like maybe more
confident too yeah yeah
growth
take the compliment all right thank you
you're like no it's not that you're like
i just know him
that was uh that was a good interview
that was fun to listen to i like that
his superpower is he wants to have
energy oh yeah yeah and at the time i
was like i'd like you to have a little
more
it'd be nice um well now we're gonna
close the show like we close every show
now by reading one of your letters
do you want to do the honors yeah i'd
love to um this is from brittany t not
testosterone yeah brittany
this is from miss testosterone brittany
t
um the subject is canadian listener so
already you know i'm in
i'm hooked morning
and there's a smiley face emoji for the
show
i think or maybe not maybe i'm reading
too much oh maybe you are i didn't think
of that hopefully it's for the show now
i'm too confident about the show we're
like when people
when people use emojis now in this
country they think of our show let's
face it
yeah we're bringing emojis back i didn't
i didn't think they went anywhere
that's good oh thanks
there should be a word for that like
questioning yourself voice the gaffing
the geek chorus yeah the key i like that
yeah some may stay too confident i'll
read the letter okay sorry
i would so this is brittany t morning
uh i did that i wouldn't typically write
in but i need to get this off my chest
another exclamation point
there are often comments about justin's
relationship status and i think
doctor thought he's funny he's
successful what's the deal
and then
a lot of ends i'm reading all the ends
then
the mcdonald's ad comes on quote four
canadians come on man i am a canadian
and i've literally never heard anyone
speak in that accent i can't speak for
everyone but i will say i've told many
people to listen to your podcast and
their first their first comments are
always
i love it thanks for the suggestion
followed up with
his stereotype of canadians is awful
you guys are great and your guests
have been unreal but maybe just one
guest yeah
i wonder which guest was unreal to her
but maybe ditch the bad impression or
you should visit canada to work on that
and then another emoji of someone like
shrugging like i don't know
um have a great weekend
cheers brittany t well that's a letter
that people aren't really going to get a
whole lot of life advice no but it was
funny and i i think you have a better
canadian accent than you get credit for
well what she see i didn't read it
properly she actually said i am a
canadian and i've listened to your show
about five times oh god that's terrible
maybe your canadian accent is getting
worse i mean it's getting worse has it
gotten bad is it bad well yeah it will
work on it anyway sorry well sorry uh
sorry britney and the other canadians
who feel that way uh but i do love your
country and i i love the people who live
in it so if anyone else wants to write
in and [ __ ] on justin's uh
bad impressions
or
[ __ ] on anything else about justin or me
uh we would love it
it's our email address is life is short
at wondery.com and we would love to hear
from you and um thank you for listening
to life is short and to jim gaffigan for
being awesome yeah and
funny how do we end this just peter out
so that's it
[Music]
thank you all canadians and
non-canadians alike for listening to our
show
life is short is hosted by me justin
long i always have to say that
and it's produced by christian long and
megan monaco our senior producer is
michelle meesch lands audio engineer is
marsha like the shortest executive
produced by
marshall louis and ernan lopez for
wondering
his first day working for him he
the only thing ray finds requested of
him like for his assistant
he wanted him to go to serve the tabla i
don't know and pick up like pick up like
some
bowl or kettle or whatever let's say
it's a kettle it doesn't matter just
like one piece
and the voicemail
was like
four and a half minutes long and
and and it was basically from ray
and it was
and it was like hello michael i would
like you to go to sir
the top
no on the corner of 64. now
and lexington
again
that's get out of here
get out of here let's get out of here
and i want you to walk into aisle three
no get the kettle and whatever
again
that's sir no no no no i don't believe
it i don't know he said sir the tobler
so
many times to remind him
and he was like thank you
again
just to be sure get out of here four and
a half minutes
he may have been doing a bit no maybe
but he was so precise and the way he
said it kept getting more like
had this guy wait who's telling you the
story
you